- The biggest thing that's
tough when you're young
is reconciling two things.
Reconciling why you see it so clearly,
and not just saying "we're young."
And two, understanding
what happens over time.
(electronic music)
♪ Me and Gary V up in the office ♪
- [Xander] Yeah.
- How you doing, bro?
- [Jace] It's good to see you, man.
I haven't seen, I like,
feel like we've talked
and I haven't seen you in so long.
- [Gary] Dude, the
lines and the hair, man.
I need to really add that to my game.
- [Jace] Oh, you like?
Dude, do it.
- I love it.
I did it in sixth grade.
- [Jace] Yeah, it was a bold move by me--
- It's hot right now.
- [Jace] And I feel good about it.
- Yeah (laughs)
- [Jace] You either love it or hate it.
They either think I'm like--
- It's faded out a little, right?
You did it a couple weeks ago?
- [Jace] Yeah, I did it awhile ago.
- [Xander] He's doing,
like, national TV with it.
- Oh, you did what?
(laughs)
- It's fortunate.
It's 'cause I'm not allowed to do anything
for the show.
Like change my look, so like,
this is the most I can do
to feel like I have control of myself.
- Are you off filming?
You're not filming right now?
- No, we're on hiatus right now.
- Got it.
It's awesome, man.
Sit, sit, sit.
- I need to introduce you,
this is my business partner,
that's my brother, X.
- I know him.
- [Gary] Hey man, how are you?
- [Jake] I'm with, I meet you with--
- [Gary] Yeah, I remember.
- [Xander] Xander.
- [Gary] How do you spell it?
- [Xander] X-A-N--
- [Gary] Oh, like my little guy.
- He actually watched your,
when did we watch Gary, dude?
- [Jake] Ah, couple years.
- He showed me you.
So he watched you--
- [Gary] Thanks, brother.
- Three years ago, four years ago?
Something like that.
- [Gary] It's awesome, it's awesome.
So what's cooking?
How are things?
- Good, I've been here
for like, a week now.
It's crazy, it's just--
- What are you doing?
- I'm doing press for the show
and the new company that I made.
- The stuff you guys are working on?
- Yeah.
- And the show airs when?
- January 19th.
- This is season what?
- Four.
And I'm coming out with
an animated show now, too.
- Are you the voice of?
- Yeah.
- That's good.
- That's awesome.
- That scales.
- Yeah, no, they're trying to,
and then we're fucking with
merchandise and stuff, so--
- So it's clicked.
- That's, yeah, it's clicked--
- It's become a franchise.
- Yeah, it's become
established a little bit.
- That's cool.
- Which is like, hard, with kind of like,
the way that TV is.
We're like, one of the only shows--
- Of course.
- That has that.
- So obviously, what I really wanna do
is really help you guys.
Obviously, we've had some interactions
and things of that nature.
And obviously, you know, we're in control
of all the cameras here.
So we don't wanna use anything sensitive.
So like, I wanna treat
this like a real meeting.
- Okay, cool.
- Like what can I help you with?
Let's start with that.
- Just kind of, I guess advice.
- Yeah.
- We're just starting out
and we're young and we're trying,
but we don't know--
- Well, what do you want to happen?
- We want this to be a,
we want the company to be the like,
kind of CAA, go-to brand.
Mark like, as far as like, the
way that people think of it,
the way that we kind of produce.
We want, like, to have all
the top kind of influencers
be going to us because of our quality
and because of the way that we--
- As a production company?
- It's a, yeah, like a production company.
- [Jake] I have a FOUR agency background.
That's why I know AJ.
I'm trying to create, with Jace,
like a comparison in the sense of like,
a celebrity-backed company that, you know,
has a good face to it.
But I want it to be a
little bit more formal,
where it's like we're not
all feeding off each other.
It's kind of each client is
managed by the same person,
but you're not dependent on each other.
Meaning I take care of
one client separately
and I take care of the next.
So kind of like a management
style type of company.
- I understand.
But the output isn't management.
The output is production content?
- Yeah, and (mumbles) management, too.
I mean--
- [Gary] So you do--
- Traditional managers (mumbles)
handling your acting stuff,
but in reverse, you know, branding work,
I mean, there's a lot
of management type of
an agent type of--
- [Gary] So management.
- Yeah, it's a fact.
I mean, my vision probably
eventually is to become
a formal management company.
- The way we pitch it isn't
like we're management.
I pitch it like we connect
brands with millions of people
using influencers and
we do it the right way,
which is not shoving it in their face.
It's integrating it right, like--
- [Gary] So you're building
a client service business.
- Yeah.
- [Jake] But the thing also is--
- [Gary] Go ahead, Xan.
- [Jake] The thing is
like, a lot of the clients
already are repped by
multiple other people,
so it's hard for us to
just come in and be like,
yo, yes, like full-service manage you.
So it's definitely--
- [Xander] We're not equipped
for full-service management.
- [Xander] But I mean,
it's definitely more
the branded content angle.
- [Jake] Another big
difference is that we're going
more after traditional celebrities
as opposed to YouTube, more like,
YouTuber slash traditional influencers.
- So your dream scenario would've been
the people behind Will
Smith starting a daily vlog?
- [Jace] Yes, exactly.
Or finding like, the Madison
Beer when she's younger
and then growing her into what she is now,
the Alexis Ren.
You know what I mean?
Do you know who those people are?
- Of course.
- Yeah, so--
- I know more about this world
than anybody in the game.
Period, end of story.
I've been there from 2006 to this moment.
- Isn't crazy how it's panned out?
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
- [Xander] Have you been watching
what he's doing (mumbles)?
- Of course.
- [Xander] I don't know who
his team is, but they're good--
- Juju naturally is good at it.
We've met with Juju from
the VaynerSports (mumbles)
- [Jake] A lot of it is like,
a natural instinct, right?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Well, that's kind of
what I'm getting at,
is it's like, there's a lot of people,
and you're not one of them,
but there's a lot of people
who are like in board meetings
trying to like, theorize
about what the kids,
I'm like, we're in it.
We're there.
- [Gary] I agree.
- These are my friends.
- [Gary] So it's very, very, very similar
to what we're doing with VaynerTalent
other than you guys are willing to
do more things than just
produce the content.
- Right.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- Do you guys know what we're
doing with VaynerTalent?
- [Jake] I'm not familiar.
- So we have, Lindsay, who was just here,
runs a division inside
here called VaynerTalent.
So like, Ray Dalio or Michael
Ovitz, who started CAA, or--
- [Jake] And I'm friends with
Arnold Lyer, who is one--
- Right, those are the
two engines behind CAA.
Like, there's people paying
us right now $20,000 a month,
$30,000 a month, to build out,
Serge Ibaka from the NBA,
like, we're wrapping up,
we do a lot of executives.
Like, so we do--
- [Jake] Oh, interesting.
- We do, like, I'm living in kind of like,
those two places--
- [Jake] Right.
- Like, you'll be more,
like, the way you pitched it,
you want him to have more of a
life that looks more like me.
He's more of an actual celebrity came up,
but I've gone down.
- [Jake] I think this is
an unprecedented territory
where I'm trying to clone.
You know, he's doing a
whole bunch of campaigns,
doing like a bunch of
videos about anti-bullying
with a bunch of different celebrities.
Like Kevin O'Leary is doing it with him
and Anthony Scaramucci
trying to build like
a mini series on that.
And both doing TODAY Show with Megyn Kelly
kind of surrounding the dyslexia angle.
I'm really trying to build Jace
out as more of a real person
as opposed to being--
- Of course.
- More inward.
'Cause right now, I think the big thing
that I've been seeing is people
who don't know Jace know Henry.
- Well, of course.
- And I want people to know Jace.
And I think that's where we
can start a (mumbles) executive
and turn it into a business--
- Sure.
- You know, a formal businessman.
Like, it's kind of contradictory
that you wear spandex
and red tights on TV,
and then he's wearing a suit and tie
going on CNBC talking business.
I'm trying to kind of create that--
- I understand.
- Bridge.
- But the business that you're
trying to build underneath
I understand, so or at least
I'm picking up the pieces.
- [Jake] Yeah, but are you trying to go
that traditional ABC route?
- I'm trying to react to
the reality of my situation
and invest in the things
that make sense, right?
Like what you guys are doing
or investing in something
that makes sense,
you know where the world's gonna,
the world's flipped, right?
And like, you guys know it, to your point,
'cause you're in it.
I have the big advantage
'cause I wasn't in it
but I knew it, and all my money
was made in investing in it,
building around it.
Like, that's what I've done, right?
- It's like when people
ask me, they're like,
where'd you come up with this idea?
I'm like, it was just kind of there.
Like, I didn't come up with it,
I just literally like saw it
and was like, "I'll do that."
- I think the game, the important,
I think the biggest thing that
you'll have to think about,
especially based on you bringing up Ronald
and your background, and the
biggest thing I would tell
all three of you is what they
had that none of us will have
is the human has much more leverage
than they did in the past.
Over the next decade--
- [Jake] Like the individual client?
- Yes, Jace has more leverage every day
and all these people, Madison and Ren.
Because they always did but
they only had three places to go
and they only had eight
places to be put on.
What your vulnerability is is--
- [Jake] Competition.
- But unlimited competition,
and unlimited and less
ways to differentiate.
Every kid is growing up getting it.
- [Jace] Yeah.
- So--
- [Xander] But that's what Jace is saying.
It's not proprietary,
but I feel like it genuinely still is--
- Oh, by the way.
Just by energy, I'm like, oh yeah,
they'll build a 10, 20, 40
million dollar business.
- [Jake] Thanks, man.
- Which is great.
But what you need to realize
is every day that it goes by,
you lose leverage, not gain.
And so as long as you're
strategizing towards that--
- [Jace] Right.
It's just about becoming
the CAA in five years.
- You know what's funny, when
you bring up Madison or Ren,
what's really super interesting,
it's actually very interesting.
The moment we had in our meeting
is the most important part of the meeting.
You asking me, "Do you know who they are?"
And me knowing who they
were the day they started
is the danger of your business.
- [Jace] But I asked, you're
the only person above 20
who I've asked and know who they are.
- I get it, I get it.
- [Xander] But as time ticks--
- That's exactly right.
- [Jace] But we're gonna
grow with it, ideally.
- [Jake] No--
- You can't outpace, you're
not gonna outpace it,
which is okay.
- [Jace] But hopefully--
- By the way--
- [Jace] But you can hope--
- Correct.
You could adjust to the leverage, right?
- But from my experience in the NBA,
when I worked with my partner
was 27 and considered,
you know, the older
quote unquote presence.
And what I found was the
players relate a lot better,
I'm sure AJ has seen this, too,
to people they can relate to.
- [Gary] But it's not an age thing, right?
- Uncomfortability--
So if AJ walked in right
now and we would say,
"AJ, of the 15 people, 9
people that VaynerSports has,
who are they relating to?
Relating to the most?"
He'd say, "You, Gary."
Why?
'Cause it's an understanding.
- But you two are
emulating, trying to like--
- [Gary] Relating, relating,
because I know more about
Will Zan than they do.
(men crosstalking)
- [Gary] But like, here's
the punchline, right?
Like, and this is an important
reason I'm bringing this up,
and this is not to be like, I'm cool.
It'll help you.
It's never gonna be about
anything other than knowing.
Like knowing, like I know
No Jumper's podcast matters
whether I'm 15 or 42,
what you need to do is
just always know more.
- [Jake] But you're an anomaly.
- No question.
Why do you think I think you
can build a 40 million thing?
If I was the norm, you
wouldn't build shit.
- Well, that's what I'm saying.
In the NBA world, you
see all these agents.
And I'm sure if somebody's
in the NFL, I know them.
They're 55, 65.
- [Gary] Ugh.
- The players think they're weird.
The players don't like them.
The question is can they
negotiate a good contract?
The answer is yes, but if you come--
- You know what's even, but you know this.
Negotiating the contract,
my eight year old daughter can do it.
- [Jace] Bullshit.
You and me are also one of the only people
who's going 100% in on the social.
Like, these people, they have agents
but those agents actually take it second.
- [Gary] No, I totally get it.
- It's like oh, you do social media?
Yeah, we'll do some social media stuff.
But let's focus on this audition.
Let's focus on this meeting--
- [Gary] Of course, 'cause
the economics are there for
(mumbles)
- It's already established.
It's funny how people don't,
like, it seems very simple.
- [Gary] But guess what?
Like, when we bought cryptocurrency
in 2013, nobody got it.
(muffled speaking)
Like, when I bought Twitter and Tumblr,
go, Jake, read it for me.
- [Xander] Hey AJ, I wanted to say thanks
for being our first ever
Uber rider in New York.
- [Gary] Period.
Like, when you're in stuff early
and you see the world
for what it actually is,
you see it for what it actually is.
The bottom line is of course, dude.
The biggest thing that's
tough when you're young
is reconciling two things.
Reconciling why you see it so clearly,
and not just saying, "We're young."
And two, understanding
what happens over time.
What gets commoditized.
Your knowledge gets commoditized.
More people will know.
People are starting to understand.
Like when Gary V., on the back
of not Entrepreneur magazine
or the Planet of the Apps,
but on the back of Instagram
and thank you, Instagram and--
- [Jake] We have been on
Breakfast Club, by the way.
- And YouTube, you know
like, yeah, that stuff.
Like that stuff is everything.
It's trading culture.
The thing that you guys have
to decide as a partnership
is what you, this is the best advice.
The two of you need to start
getting unbelievably real
with each other about how you care about
the next 12 days, 12 weeks,
12 months and 12 years,
because that's the only
thing that matters.
- [Jake] One thing he and I
do have is a pretty open--
- I believe in you, but both of you
are holding certain
things back as you should.
It's human nature.
- Not me.
- [Gary] But you know
what subconscious bias is?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] That's what we all do.
- I'm kind of nuts, though.
- [Gary] Respect, but no human's, me too,
but guess what.
But there's still other stuff
and it's about anticipation.
What happens if you fall in
love with a crazy person?
What happens if your mother gets sick?
Like, I'm talking everything.
Not like how good you want
to feel transparently,
like I wanna screw him.
Most people don't want to screw people.
- No, I agree.
Really delve into the nooks and crannies.
- Of course, so like, to me,
I think it's super important
for you to think about
that, because here's why.
The business you're starting now
is not gonna be the
business you're gonna be in
in three years, and definitely not six,
and definitely not 10.
And the question will become
are you excited about you,
you have the...
You've gravitated
towards loving that game,
which I also love.
I can deal with people's
bullshit for the rest of my life.
It's innate to me and that's
what doing human stuff with.
- [Jace] What do you mean
other people's bullshit?
- Well, if you get into
anything that looks like CAA
or William Morris or the
stuff you've been doing,
or the NBA or VaynerSports--
- [Jace] Yeah.
- You're in the people business.
Cool, it sounds great
right now, but when you're,
even if you get to the
greatest holy grail tomorrow
being the exclusive social
media content provider
and manager of Beyonce,
you're in the Beyonce's
personality business.
- [Jake] Yeah, mhm.
So I also started in sales business.
- [Gary] Of course you are.
Of course, but the product--
- He's the salesman.
- [Gary] Of course.
- The older agents don't realize that.
They think they're in this
like, super C special,
and I'm just like, you're a sales guy.
You're selling a product to the team--
- [Gary] A hundred percent.
- And you have to think
about it like that.
- [Gary] Now look, it
takes a certain temperament
and talent to sell human.
The real business for you
guys is these real celebrities
are about to eat so much humility.
And if you can be the
people that tame them,
from going to a pedestal
down to the trenches
to build back up to a pedestal,
it's an incredibly big opportunity.
See what I mean?
- [Jake] Yeah.
- You guys are right, you're right.
Yeah, yeah, it's, look, you know this.
It's proprietory in
your handling of people.
- [Jace] Why do you think
that these celebrities are,
'cause for me, I was always--
- Here's why.
- [Jace] I'm on TV--
- I'll tell you why.
- [Jace] I'm always
terrified of TV going away.
You know what I mean?
- [Jake] The honest thing is--
- [Jace] Like why are
they not more afraid?
Why are they not thinking?
- They're not afraid
'cause they are afraid,
but they have too much ego.
The only thing a real
celebrity, not you, a real A--
- [Jace] Yep.
- Not a B or C--
- [Jake] Not you.
- Not you.
I'm talking a real A.
- [Jace] Yeah.
- Like the biggest
celebrities in the world
who are fucking this up, right?
Is that they don't have the
humility to start at zero.
- [Jake] Come back down to earth.
- That's right.
When you are a big time celebrity--
- [Jake] Yeah, I get that.
- For the last 10 years,
and you have to start
an Instagram tomorrow
'cause you have to.
- [Jace] Will Smith, Will Smith.
- But Will Smith does have the humility--
- [Xander] I know, but I'm saying--
- Which is why he's
gonna fucking dominate.
- [Xander] That's the reason--
- He's still hungry.
But a million people I'm
sure we can name right now,
the reason they're not
doing it is they don't like
having 5,000 followers that first day.
- [Jace] 'Cause then it makes them look
like they're nothing.
(X speaks muffledly)
They can't take that.
- Of course they need it because--
- [Jake] Why?
- Go read the transition
of radio to television.
Of course they need it.
- [Jake] I know, but some
of them are just like,
whatever happens happens.
- Oh, listen--
- I'm really good friends with (mumbles)
- Brother, brother, brother,
that's a whole different story.
Like if you don't give
a fuck, nothing matters.
- [Jake] True.
- You know what I mean?
- [Jake] I think it's a
lot of the old actors--
- That's fine.
Brother, that's fine.
- [Jake] Oh well, I'm
gonna have enough money
to last me (mumbles)
- A hundred percent, but
you know what kicks in?
Tasting irrelevance.
You know the scariest place
right now is to be a solid B.
Because a solid B is awesome
but it's about to get really not awesome.
It's all the same game, brother.
The same people that you're
talking to that I'm talking to
all see the world the same way.
I think the biggest, so
here's the difference between
where I'm at and where you're at.
And I think it'll be a good
thing for you to debate
on the differences and
decide what that means to you
as you think about the next 50 years.
I have decided to eat shit
and build these non-exciting
EBITDA businesses, like
we're talking right now,
for one reason.
Because I'm gonna buy
PONY or Cracker Jacks
or Captain Crunch, take the energy,
buy something for 288
million, and sell it for 1.7.
I'm gonna do Champion.
What happened to Champion
over the last three years
is what I'm gonna do
one day with something.
- [Jake] Do you know if you're saying
you wanna take a preexisting brand--
- Correct.
- [Jace] You know what I'm doing right now
is my brand is as big as it ever has been
and maybe ever will be.
So right now, I know I
wanna do entrepreneurship.
I know I wanna do bigger things, so--
- [Gary] I would--
- Say look, I'm doing this--
- [Gary] I would argue it's
the smallest it will ever be--
- [Jace] Look long term--
- If you're ever bought
into where it is right now.
The way you're talking,
so here's what's funny--
- But listen, but listen--
- [Jake] It's a combination
of he doesn't know where he wants--
- [Jace] No, no, no, listen, listen.
It's macro, it's the smallest.
I'm saying I could die for
five years, establish myself,
say I've already done this
company, grind, grind, grind
for ten more years, and
then get to another thing.
I just need to use this juice
that I've got to just grow.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
- [Gary] Two things.
Of course I understand.
Two things.
That's right, but it will
get exponentially bigger
if you do this thing.
The fact that you're--
- Right, no, I'm not saying
I'm not doing this thing--
- No, no, meaning everything
that you guys are talking about
is exactly, it's gonna just get bigger.
Like it's great--
- [Jace] What's gonna just get bigger?
- Your juice.
Like, the bigger you get
on Instagram, Snapchat,
Facebook and podcasting is gonna make you,
as big as Nickelodeon is,
they'll just play off of each other.
(muffled speaking)
It's the reason why I'm
willing to do TV if it's right.
Apple won for me before it started
because it was behind a pay
wall and all this other stuff.
It didn't matter, it just
positioned me differently--
- [Jake] Right.
- In a world that I know
is dying, Hollywood,
but it mattered for me in the short term
'cause you're always just
balancing out your gain.
- [Xander] Was it about, like,
putting yourself peer to Peer With--
- [Gary] Of course.
I won on the day of the announcement.
It just subconsciously put
me on a different place
to the masses.
- [Xander] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Right?
That's all.
- What do you think about,
like the whole celebrity entrepreneurship
that's kind of happening right now?
Like you, I'm not gonna
put you in that same realm,
but Elon Musk and like,
there's this kind of like,
you're just kind of like--
- [Gary] Yeah, it's cycles.
It's cycles, it's cycles.
- It's almost like these
people who are creating things
are now the new, almost new celebrities
because of what they've done.
- Brother, do you know how
not famous athletes were
in the thirties and forties?
There was a couple but not collectively.
The NBA Finals in 1983 was on tape delay.
They didn't even show it live.
- Well, what's interesting is now,
but now it's not a money game anymore.
Now it's a what can you do game.
Like Elon Musk, it's like Elon
Musk or some billionaire--
- Hold on, Jake, is it
a money game for you?
Yes.
- [Jake] Everything's a money game.
- No, no, no, I mean big, big scale.
Big, big, big.
- [Gary] I mean, listen, it
all depends on the person.
Jake could have answered no, by the way.
Let me give you my story.
This is just true.
- I'm just saying who's
gonna go down in history,
the YouTube billionaire or--
- [Gary] I get it.
- I mean the super
billionaire or the Elon Musk
who spent all of his money on Tesla?
Do you know what I'm saying?
- Legacy is always different than money.
Nobody who ended up with the
most money is remembered.
- [Jace] That's what I'm saying.
- Yeah, but that's because
everything is being documented.
- [Jace] Right.
- That's the difference now.
- [Xander] Did you change up your strategy
on that by the way?
- What do you mean?
- [Xander] The whole, like,
document pre-screening?
- Meaning?
- [Xander] Like, that was
what you were pitching
for awhile, right?
- That's my biggest belief.
- [Xander] But you haven't
switched up on that at all.
'Cause haven't you been trying
to do more narrative stuff?
- Like what?
- I don't know, I just
heard you mentioning
you were trying to do, like,
more creative narrative-based stuff.
- I just want to make sure I understand.
Maybe the answer is maybe,
I just want to understand the question.
- [Xander] Oh okay, so for
awhile you were pitching like,
I'm not creating, I'm documenting.
- Which is what I'm doing right now.
- [Xander] Yes, but what do you,
do you consider like, the
podcast content documentation
or do you consider that creative--
- No, I consider that creative,
but no, I think that's creative,
and by the way,
the first thing I ever did was creative.
Wine Library TV wasn't
gonna be documenting.
I did a wine show for 30 minutes, right?
- [Xander] Yeah.
- [Jace] What year did you do that?
- 2006.
- [Jace] Online?
- [Jake] I have an
interest so (audio drops)
reached out to me (mumbles)
A friend of mine,
and they want to do a podcast
with Jace on entrepreneurship.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Jace] What do you think of that?
- He's kind of iffy on it
and I want to get your take.
- Oh, you should definitely do a podcast.
- [Jace] We're not gonna do a
podcast without (audio drops)
- Yes, you should just--
- [Jace] So is it worth it?
- Yes, I look at audio
as just so important
that you have to be on it.
- I think for us, it's a combination.
- I always keep hearing
that audio is the next thing
and I don't understand it.
- [Gary] 'Cause it's passive consumption.
It's the same reason Uber worked.
- Like when they're going to sleep
or waking up in the morning,
when they're driving--
- [Gary] When they're driving,
they're not fucking
wondering if Henry Danger--
- I wasn't sure what was,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah--
- I listened to (mumbles)
podcast every morning
and then, you know, I listen to--
- But how much value--
- [Gary] Let me give you some, amazingly--
- But if you're not paying attention--
- [Gary] No, no, you're half
paying attention to everything.
Like it's all the same,
let me give you a great piece of advice.
The written word, audio
and video are gonna be here
long after we're gone,
have been here long before.
All of the platforms always matter,
they just go up and
down in their importance
based on technology.
The radio was a hell of a lot
more important than video,
you know, for a moment
there, and then this and that
and so they bounce up and down.
The car radio was super important.
Having a morning talk show
in the car was a monster.
Howard Stern was a monster.
So you've got, it goes up and down.
- [Xander] Do you feel
like, within the past year,
podcasts have just become super saturated?
- Everything gets saturated when it,
do you think influencers
have become super saturated?
It's supply and demand.
The supply is not equal to the demand yet.
And guess what else happens next?
Talent rises to the top.
Do you know how many
social media guru and
businessmen there are?
- [Xander] Yes.
- There's a difference between me and them
because I'm more talented than them.
- That goes for acting, too.
- [Gary] Of course it does.
- There's a double, there's a like--
- [Gary] It goes for everything in life.
The end.
- [Xander] Yeah, it's just--
- There's nothing else to really say.
- [Jace] It doesn't
matter if you're willing
to stick it out.
- Dude, when I tell you--
- [Jace] It doesn't
matter if you're willing--
- You'll love this, as
soon as you're done texting
I'll tell you something you're gonna love.
- [Jake] Growing with
a platform or with a--
- Of course, can I tell
you what that's called?
Somebody bought beachfront
property at Malibu
when it first came out.
Some man and woman walked
in and they were like,
"Fuck it, we'll take a chance."
- [Xander] Yeah.
- Now, it's still great,
it's just way more expensive.
(Xander speaks muffledly)
I was on YouTube in 2006.
That was what I gave.
Twitter, I was one of the first people
with a million followers.
That was the foundation.
- I feel like Twitter's got a resurgence
because of politics.
I feel like it was
dying there for a second
and now it's kind of--
- [Gary] It all depends
on what you use it for.
- But now it's like a main
kind of source for information
about the world.
- [Gary] Yeah, I mean it always was.
It just--
- It just wasn't like--
- [Gary] It's on your mind right now
because of the politics stuff.
Let me tell you this, though.
Fake humility sucks.
- 'Cause it's like, you're fake as hell.
- [Gary] It's shit.
- It just comes across like you're bigger.
- But the thing is you
suck it up and you do it.
- I do it when I know that
I'm wearing my, your jersey,
and I don't do it when
I'm wearing his jersey.
I play both, which is weird.
- [Xander] So what did you have first?
- [Jace] What jersey did you have first?
- [Xander] Personal brand Gary versus--
- Well I was, nobody
knew who the fuck I was
until I was 34 years old.
So I was a businessman my whole life,
so it wasn't like super hard,
that was my first jersey.
That's what's worked for me.
He's the reverse.
- I could put on a different
jersey at a different time.
Like you--
- [Gary] Yeah, when you
go, look, look, look.
You don't roll up on Fat Joe and be like,
of course you know who I am.
But when you're in a meeting
and you're playing the exec,
but look, by the way,
this is the wrong answer.
Just keep doing what you're doing.
Keep doing what you're doing--
- [Jace] Right, I just--
- And that's it.
And both, by the way, you
guys just had an exchange
that has always been my biggest issue.
You both put, you just have
to both default starting now
'cause you're both alpha
winners and wanna win
into we both, we put--
- [Jake] We do the we.
- No, no, but no, no,
I'm watching you guys.
Listen to me.
This is what I talk about
12 days, 12 months, 12,
I want you guys to win.
I don't give a fuck.
You guys do the we at certain times
and you do the, I'll
replay the video tape of
The Breakfast Club
statement two seconds ago.
He just said that's the reason
I can get into (mumbles)
And you said I got you into (mumbles)
Brother, because it's true.
It's true.
- [Jake] Right, both of
your statements are not--
- His brand, they're both true.
And the biggest issue I have
with my other alpha partners
is we both think it was us.
I think everything that
VanderSports is gonna do is me.
But it's also AJ.
Like--
- [Xander] AJ works his ass off.
- Do you know what I mean?
So like, it's just, so you guys will lose
if you don't fight every day for we
and understand that truth.
- We're gonna do this, man.
- [Gary] And it's B+, A-.
- Right.
- Got you.
- I'm literally living the life
a couple months ahead of you,
couple years ahead of
you that you're living.
That's all.
That's what being older
is good about, you know?
Like now you're fucking set.
Now you're set.
He's not--
- Do you feel so old?
- Yeah, you know, compared to you guys.
I feel young as fuck but you
fuckers are young as shit.
You know, so listen, I'm here for you guys
because I've thought through
some of these things a ton.
How do you scale something,
somebody who doesn't wanna be
not authentic and not like,
there's a very specific reason
that I'm winning this thing
and I know I'm gonna win it
the most out of anybody.
It's because I've been doing
it for a much longer time
than most, and number
two, I care about both.
- Yeah, thanks man, I really
appreciate it, seriously.
- It's really good to see you, bro.
- Thank you.
- Oh, let me take a picture.
Oh, actually, wait a minute,
you got my, wait a minute.
This is the advantage you have.
My daughter watches this shit.
I gotta get something good.
This is your biggest fuckin' arbitrage.
- [Xander] Can we all
get a picture, though?
- Yeah, of course.
Just say, Mischa, your daddy's the best
or something like that.
- Alright.
What's her name, Mischu?
- Mischa, ready?
- What's up, Mischa?
I'm here, we're hanging out with your dad.
Convince him to come down
to LA, we'll get a set tour
and we'll hang out.
- I promise, Misch.
- We just made a promise.
- I will deliver on it.
Alright, let's take a photo.
- [Woman] One, two, three?
Cool.
- Awesome, can you email me that?
- Really appreciate it, man.
- It's good to see you, brother.
- Thanks.
- Good to see ya.
- Appreciate it.
(upbeat hip hop music)